[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
ROBBIE: Hey, dad.
Can I ask you a question?
TODD: Why sure Robbie.
That's what I'm here for.
ROBBIE: Yeah, speaking of which,
aren't you supposed to be like,
at a job or something?
TODD: Listen Robbie, I'm
in between opportunities
right now.
And so I'm taking that time
to build up my personal brand
and my social media presence.
ROBBIE: Hmm.
So you mean you're like, on
Twitter all day and stuff, dad?
[LAUGHTER]
TODD: It's grown up stuff.
You wouldn't understand.
Anyway, what's your question?
ROBBIE: Well, you remember last
time I installed a CocoaPod,
its version number
had a squiggly arrow
in front of it and stuff?
TODD: I sure do.
ROBBIE: Well, you never really
did tell me what that means,
dad.
TODD: Why I guess
I didn't, did I?
Well, follow me, Robbie,
to the wall of knowledge.
ROBBIE: Oh, you mean that
projector screen over there?
[LAUGHTER]
TODD: Just watch me.
So to answer your
question a little better,
I probably need
to explain to you
what semantic versioning is.
In semantic
versioning, libraries
have version numbers
that are broken
into three parts that look a
little something like this.
Now, let's explore these
numbers from right to left.
The number on the right
is the patch number.
As a general rule,
anytime an author
makes any kind of bug
fix to their library that
doesn't break backwards
compatibility--
and let's face it,
you shouldn't be
breaking backwards
compatibility for a bug
fix-- they increment
this number.
The number in the middle is
the minor release number.
Library authors
will increment this
when they add a new feature.
But again, generally,
if they do it
in a backwards compatible way.
Now the number on the left
is the major release number.
Library authors
will increment this
when they make changes
to their code that
breaks backwards compatibility.
ROBBIE: I think I get it.
So, if you fixed a crash
bug in your library--
TODD: I might change the
version number to 1.4.8,
as long as the change
is backwards compatible.
ROBBIE: And if you
added a new feature?
TODD: I would change the
version number to 1.5.0.
ROBBIE: OK.
But let's say you
made a fix that
changed the signature of
some of your method calls.
TODD: Right.
Well, that's not
backwards compatible.
So I might change
my version to 2.0.0.
ROBBIE: Oh.
I get it.
But wait.
You still haven't explained what
the squiggly line means, dad.
TODD: Well, let's say you
have version 1.4.7 installed.
Would you want CocoaPods
to automatically
update your library to 1.4.8
when you call pod update?
ROBBIE: Well, that sounds safe.
Because it's not breaking
the change, right?
You're just fixing
the crash bug.
TODD: That's right.
Now, let's say you
have version 1.4.8.
Would you want CocoaPods
to automatically
update your library to 1.5.0
when you call pod update?
ROBBIE: Well, yeah, I guess so.
I mean, the developers have
just added new features.
Nothing should break, right?
TODD: Yeah, that's
probably true.
ROBBIE: Probably?
TODD: We'll get back to that.
So here's the $64,000 question.
Let's say you have
version 1.5.0.
Would you want CocoaPods
to automatically
update your library to 2.0.0
when you call pod update?
ROBBIE: Well, probably not.
You've changed the
major version, which
means there's changes in
there that will break my code
and my project won't compile.
TODD: Correct.
You got it.
ROBBIE: Hooray!
But what does any
of this have to do
with the squiggly arrow, dad?
TODD: So the
squiggly arrow means
that you're OK letting
CocoaPods automatically
upgrade your library,
but only if it
increments the last version
number you specified.
ROBBIE: Hmm?
TODD: Let's say you have
squiggly arrow 1.4.7.
That means you're totally fine
having CocoaPods upgrade you
to 1.4.8, 1.4.9, and
1.4.10, but not 1.5.0.
Similarly, squiggly
arrow 1.4 means
you're fine having
CocoaPods upgrade you
to 1.4.8, 1.4.9, 1.5.0,
1.6.2, but not, say, 2.0.0.
ROBBIE: Well, what if I
have squiggly arrow 1 1?
TODD: Well, that means you're OK
having CocoaPods automatically
update your library to
just about anything.
At that point you might as well
not include any version number
at all.
ROBBIE: Well that seems
pretty worthless, dad.
TODD: It is.
Just like my brother-in-law.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBBIE: And what if I don't want
to use a squiggly line at all,
dad?
TODD: CocoaPod supports a number
of operations all of which
work pretty much
like you'd expect.
ROBBIE: OK.
So, hmm, why would I ever
want to upgrade just the patch
version?
It seems like I should be able
to upgrade the patch version
and and the minor
version anytime I want.
Right, dad?
TODD: Well, in theory yes.
In practice
sometimes you'll find
the developers do add small
breaking changes here or there
when they upgrade
their minor version.
Maybe developers
making bug fixes,
and it turns out
one of their fixes
adds another argument
to one of their methods.
Well, you know, technically
it's non-backwards compatible.
The API surface has changed.
But changing the major
version seems pretty drastic
here for what's essentially
a minor bug fix.
And so perhaps they compromise
and change the minor version
instead.
Usually these situations
are pretty easy to fix.
But they do happen.
ROBBIE: But doesn't that break
the whole semantic versioning
rule?
TODD: Well, yes.
But it's important to remember
that semantic versioning is
just a convention.
Nobody anywhere is going to
enforce it, or eject a CocoaPod
that doesn't follow it.
And so, there is a small
risk that your code
might break even when only the
minor version number changes.
So you'll find that some
CocoaPod users are only
comfortable updating
their libraries
when the patch number changes.
Other developers are OK
with updating their library
when the minor number changes.
It probably depends
on how much you
feel like living on the
edge, and how comfortable
you feel with a pod developer
following semantic versioning.
ROBBIE: So what about Google?
Have they promised to
follow semantic versioning
in their CocoaPods, dad?
TODD: I think it's safe to
say most groups at Google
try to follow
semantic versioning.
But the groups that are part
of the new, automated CocoaPod
publishing process are
a little better at it.
ROBBIE: Well, that'll help
me sleep better at night.
Say, does this squiggly line
have an official name dad?
TODD: Yes, it's called
a twiddle wakka.
ROBBIE: You're joking, right?
TODD: I don't joke
about things like this.
[LAUGHTER]
So there you go son.
All your questions about
the squiggly arrow answered.
ROBBIE: Don't you mean the
twiddle wakka wakkas, dad?
[LAUGHTER]
TODD: Oh.
But seriously, correct me again
and I will cut your [BLEEP]
[BLEEP] off.
[AUDIENCE GROAN]
ROBBIE: Don't you mean
the twiddly wakkas, dad?
TODD: But seriously,
correct me again,
I'm going to ship you
off to military school.